[音楽]
もし
今日が人生最後の日だとしたら
あなたは
どんなことを後悔しますか
あーもっと毎日飲み歩いたかよかったなぁ
あーもっと可愛いベンチャーといっぱい遊んどくべきだったなぁ
そんなことをいちばんに後悔する人は
まずいないと思います
じゃ
何を思うのか
死を間近にした時
大半の人は
こんな後悔の言葉を口にするそうです
自分にとっての幸せともっと
向き合えばよかった
私が看護師時代に受け持っていたおじいちゃんも
まさに同じことを言っていました
おじいちゃんは末期ガンでした
そんなおじいちゃんと車いすで散歩に出かけたある日
窓の外を眺めながらおじいちゃんは私にこんな話をしてくれパンです
私はこれまで
当たり前のように終電まで働き
お金を稼ぐための人生を生きてきた
それが正しいと思っとった
でも
死を間近にした今
大切なのはお金じゃなく
科学とな時間だったと
今更ながらに気づいたよ
わしは年をとってからしか
こんな大事なことにも気づけんかったが
君はまだ若い
人生は一度きりだ
軍に通っての幸せと
ゆっくり向き合って
後悔のない人生を
歩みなさい
あの時の情景は今でも鮮明に覚えています
死を間近にしたおじいちゃんのあまりにも説得力のあるメッセージは
わたしの心にズシリと響きました
そんなとき
あるテレビ番組で世界の幸福度ランキングっていうのを特集していました
当時のムチだ私はまあ日本は豊かだし当然
トップ10くらいには入ってるでしょ
そんなふうに思いながらその番組を見ていたんですけど
日本より貧しい国がどんどんランクインする中で
日本は
皆さんないだと思いますか
日本はまさかの9ずーい
お気楽な学生生活を撮って送っていた私にとって
それはあまりにも衝撃的で
ショックなものでした
日本はこんなにも豊かで恵まれているのに
幸せを実感できていない人がたくさんいるんだッ
豊かさ=幸せにはならないのか
そもそも幸せとは何なのか
その答えが知りたくて
私は世界一周の旅に出ることを決めました
私の価値観が
大きく変わるストーリーの始まりです
初めての一人旅
荷物を盗まれたり
どんなにどんなに歩いても泊まらせてくれるホテルが見つからず
一人で凍えそうになりながら野宿をしたりと
大変なこともたくさんありましたが
そんなことは忘れてしまうくらい
世界は素晴らしいべ愛に溢れていました
ここで一つ
私の旅のテーマでもあった
幸せ探しに大きなヒントをくれた
カンボジアのある村を紹介したいと思います
アンコールワットのあるセムリアップという街からバイクで約2時間
そこに人口1000人ほどの
ブサイという小さな村があります
この村には
電気もガスも水道も
家の扉さえありませんでしたが
どこまでも続く青い空のスタ0
土の中系などまではしゃぐ
子どもたちのキラキラ輝く笑顔がありました
食べに出る前
私はこんな風にも持っていました
貧しい国の人がもし日本に来たら
あまりの日便利さと豊かさを知って自分の国には帰れなくなっちゃうんじゃないかなっ
て
この村で唯一日本に来たことのあったサムに私はこんな質問をしました
ねぇねぇサム
ずっと日本にいたいとは思わなかったの
サムは答えました
もちろん日本はコンビニも電車回っ
あまりの便利さに僕は最初感動したよ
だけど
ずっと居たいと思ったことは
一度もなかったんだ
日本には僕の心を癒してくれる場所がなかった
この村は貧しいけど
心を癒してくれる豊かな自然がたくさんある
僕が幸せに暮らすには
コンビニも連射も必要ないっ
日本に行って気づいたんだよ
私はその時
必ずしも
物質的な豊かさ=幸せではないんだということを
サメに
教えてもらいました
そんな学びを胸に
世界数ど旅を終え
日本に帰国したわけですが
日本という国は本当に惑わせ上手です
あんなにも度で必ずしも
豊かさ=幸せではないって
マナーなのに
とにかくいろんな角度から私のことを惑わせてきます
さあマンションに住む雑誌のセレブ妻た句集
剛行するために繰り広げられる a その1どこの開祖なの練習は
という対話
いつしか私も
自分の思い描く幸せに自信がなくなり
自分を
に失ってしまいました
こんな具合に
この複雑なメイドから何とか脱出すべく
何度もグーグル先生に相談しました
自分に合う人を見つけ方
もちろん的確な答えを教えてもらえません
なのでもがきました
とにかく毎週のように強盗を繰り返しました
そしたら
出会えたんです
大富豪に
違います
無職の男性に
僕もうすぐ仕事を辞めて世界一周の旅に行こうと思ってるんだよね
そんな風に話す
間もなく6速になる男性に出会いました
彼は言います
なんとなく日本はお金持ち=幸せみたいなイメージがあるけどなんか違う気がするんだ
よね
だから僕は世界を食べしていっ
いろんな人と出会っ
いろんな価値観に触れた上でこれからの人生を作っていきたいと思ってるんだ
カットしました
この人と7思い描いた幸せがつかめるかもしれない
直感的にそう思いました
忘れかけていたものを
思い出させてくれたのが
今日も来てくれてるんですけど
今の旦那さんです
周りが車を買い
家を買い始める
30歳手前でを
私たち夫婦は
性も
仕事も貯金も失いましたが
まったく後悔していません
こんな絶景に出会いだのだから
まるで宇宙かのような
ウユニ塩湖の満天の星空
未だ謎に包まれた
ペルーのマチュピチュつ
恋人と一緒に歩くと願いが叶うと言われている
ウクライナの会えのトンネル
1周目は一人旅
2週目は2人旅
これまで世界を2周し70カ国を旅してきて
幸せの形は人それぞれなんだということ
を身を以て
知ることができました
そして
気付いたんです
自分にとっての幸せと向き合うことが
いかに重要か
食べる前の私は自分にとっての幸せと真剣に向き合ったことって多分なかったんですよ
ね
でもそれって
私だけでしょうか
できるだけ良い学校に入るため
できるだけ良い回戦に入るため
できるだけたくさんのお金を稼ぐためには膨大な時間を使って努力をするのに
肝心の自分にとっての幸せと向き合う時間は
あまりに少ないように思います
いい学校に入れば幸せになれる
いい大佐に入れば幸せになれる
お金持ちになれば幸せになれる
そんな
世間が作り出した
幸せのカタチだけを信じ
自分にとっての幸せと向き合うことを
忘れてはいませんでしょうか
おじいちゃんが教えてくれていたように
後悔しない人生を歩む一番の近道は
自分にとっての幸せと
向き合うことなのです
なので皆さん
ぜひ
今日という日をきっかけに
忙しい日常から一度立ち止まって
自分にとっての幸せとゆっくり
向き合ってみてください
そしていつか死ぬ前に
最高に幸せな人生だった
そんな風に
胸を張って言える人生を
自分の手で
作って欲しいなと思います
あなたにとっての幸せは
何ですか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]